[Musique]
nous sommes au stade de la redoute et je
veux raconter une partie de l'histoire
du sport à la réunion
en 1940 à 1946 c'était un hippodrome la
piste à aller jusqu'au monument des
anglais c'était l'après guerre mais a
faim c'est ça venait surtout de l'île
maurice que c'est les anglais qui a
amené les scream à la réunion la boxe
et côté compagnies déjà des relations
entre les îles vous êtes tout à fait ces
relations ont été concrétisés par la
ligue rennaise de football à travers le
le tournoi triangulaire qui réunissait
donc maurice madagascar réunion
l'osmose entre
le structures d'état puisque jeunesse et
sports été mis en place en 1947 et le
monde sportif grâce à des associations
telles que l'eau reste
tel que le cross qui ont été mis en
place dont il ya eu une forme de passage
de pouvoirs entre l'état et les
associations sportives ne faut pas
oublier les écoles les relations avec
les écoles élémentaires grâce à lui
c'est pas grâce à l'ufolep et
grâce aussi à la su qui était à l'époque
lou suez qui est devenu l'urss
j'étais enseignant d'éducation physique
et enseignante ou quoi puisque j'étais
dans des écoles élémentaires aussi c'est
ce que j'appellerais le saas 1 le
passage des méthodes le passage des
structures le passage de la prise de
conscience aussi parce que le sport n'a
pas toujours été reconnu comme une
activité éducative et surtout une est
une lacune activités concourant à la
santé des individus fait du sport c'est
tout perdre sur temps et maintenant on
reconnaît la valeur du sport et avec la
crise sanitaire à l'heure actuelle on se
rend compte que le sport est
indispensable est plus que nécessaire
on était source ou les tamarins a
souhaité à marignier pardon
pour le repas du midi et puis on
regardait les courses de chevaux les
quoi 7,6 pissou où les matches de
football les grands matchs de football
ici a eu lieu des deux célèbres victoire
en particulier celle du saint denis en
coupe de france contre libourne la
départementalisation a surtout
rapprocher la réunion de la mère patrie
ne pas oublier non plus les liaisons
aériennes et maritimes à l'époque aller
en métropole c'était c'était pas facile
beaucoup de deux d'athlètes réunionnais
aurait pu peut-être faire une carrière
en métropole je me rappelle de d'une
expression d'un élu très connu à la
réunion
lorsque je suis rentré dans mon son
bureau après la victoire en coupe
nationale des cadets m'a dit
la réunion qui gagne c'est hyper
important
gagner ce n'est pas simplement un sport
son économie dans l'éducation et la
réunion qui gagne il a il a tout résumé
dans cette expression
[Musique]